[Musique]
le château de chamerolles est connue des
visiteurs pour ces hirondelles
elles reviennent chaque année niché à
l'orée de la forêt d'orléans qu'elle se
met là entre les poutres elle se met
aussi au niveau du châtelet au sommet il
ya des petits recoins donc au printemps
vous avez quasiment annie dans chaque
recoin
donc ce sont les hirondelles qui ont été
vraiment le point de départ du refuge
lp des hirondelles des verdier d'europe
des aigles beauté les troglodytes mignon
ont leurs habitudes à chabrol une
cinquantaine d'espèces a été recensée la
plupart protéger elles ont valu au
château d'être labellisé refuge par la
ligue de protection des oiseaux
[Musique]
c'est un périmètre qui est à peu près à
100 150 mètres autour du château la kia
qui est derrière ou donc ça va inclure
le miroir d'eau qui est juste ici les
jardins renaissance qui sont à peu près
à qui font deux hectares
et puis une partie du domaine boisé qui
autour du château grâce à la diversité
de son milieu et à sa nourriture
abondante
le refuge de chabrol est il en passe de
devenir un sanctuaire pour les oiseaux
alors que leur population décroît chaque
année un peu plus les refuges peuvent
répondre un petit peu à cette question
parce qu'un refuge c'est simplement un
terrain privé au public ou propriétaires
s'engagent à protéger la nature et à
développer la biodiversité
donc chacun peut faire ça déjà ne
serait-ce qu'un particulier dans son
jardin un établissement un château voilà
et en effet ça permet la multiplication
des oiseaux enfin à chabrol des nichoirs
seront bientôt installés pour faciliter
la reproduction la découverte de la
biodiversité sur elle intégré au
programme de la visite
comme c'est le cas des vingt-sept mille
refuge el teo de france